alors c'est un très beau film qui m'a
beaucoup ému j'ai vraiment été touché
par le caractère de matt damon par les
images qui étaient vraiment un très
belle très beau film
j'ai beaucoup aimé la façon dont il a
été créatifs puis j'ai beaucoup aimé son
moral dacic
aujourd'hui les principales agences la
nasa ce évalue à environ 2000 35 36 37
la date où un premier équipage pour
rester sur mars environ un mois et avant
ça pourrait être précédé de 2 min 31 de
mission sur les satellites de mars
dans le film il ya des fusées qui
partent de la terre qui sont tout à fait
classique
et puis il ya un très beau vaisseau qui
fait le voyage vers mars qui est à
propulsion électrique d'ailleurs on voit
bien le fonctionner propulseur donc ça
se voit soit un petit peu de science
fiction dans les premières missions on
aura des vaisseaux beaucoup plus simple
que ce qui est présenté dans le film à
la propulsion en particulier ont oscillé
fusée qui décolle de mars c'est tout à
fait réaliste alors cultivée sur mars y
aura sûrement comme le montre la
maquette qui est à côté de moi dès le
début des tentatives qui sont peut-être
aussi au départ des cultures
hydroponiques c'est-à-dire dans lequel
on n'utilise pas le sol martien mais on
va vouloir voir assez vite si on peut
utiliser sur le martien et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya quand même quelques
difficultés qu'il faut arrive à se
débarrasser de quelques éléments qui a
dans le sol martien pour faire pousser
facilement des plantes
moi j'ai trouvé ce film tout à fait
intéressant parce que sur beaucoup
d'aspects il est très proche de la
réalité
la problématique de mars notamment le
fait que les hommes pourront rester 30
jours ou 512 x mais entre les deux vous
êtes obligés de rester toujours en vie
il faut il faut le voir comme une grande
aventure assez réaliste qui est en plus
et un aspect salvateur c'est qu'on fait
on fait confiance à des gens qui sont au
sol ont fait confiance à tout ce qui
peut se passer dans la vie
moi je trouve sa fille vraiment très
très très très positif un quotidien
d'astronautes c'est un quotidien qui est
très réglée il faut pas qu'ils
s'ennuient et d'ailleurs dans le film il
s'ennuie pas s'il ya tellement de choses
à faire le pot pour survivre si c'est
pas de vie réglée
eh ben ça ça part très vite en n'importe
quoi et c'est ce qu'on demande à un
astronaute c'est lui au moins qu'il
fasse sa mission vraiment je recommande
c'est un très très beau film très très
bien tourné je m'appelle maroilles mais
je suis toujours mais c'est un film très
bien documenté ya très très peu
d'erreurs scientifiques et techniques et
les paysages sont splendides les
maquettes sont très belles
voilà une belle réussite de ridley scott
j'aime beaucoup les paysages heures avec
mars
l'arrêt des scot avec très très bien
inspiré s'est documenté il a tourné en
guady rome en jordanie
donc c'est assez proche de certains
paysages de mars donc
face à cette situation accablante je
n'ai pas le choix je vais devoir en
fichiers de la science